and Dana on the issue of substance that
Juan brought up saying that this is a
kind of a referendum on trumpism like I
would take issue with that obviously in
Alabama as Brett said but you know going
forward with the immigration trade deals
deregulatory efforts judges where does
this leave the Republican Party when you
have a flake Murkowski Collins and
McCain who are obviously on many issues
really on the opposite side of Donald
Trump well I think in many ways actually
the president's in pretty good shape on
that as Brett has been saying all night
that the tax reform bill is going to get
voted on most likely before Jones has
ever set and I'm not convinced that he
wouldn't have voted for it anyway but
let's just say they say they get tax
reform done then the president has said
he wants to move on and do border
security immigration and an
infrastructure bill Democrats want to
work on an infrastructure bill there's
nothing here that would change the path
of judges and on trade I think that the
president actually can do a lot just
administrative Lee so actually the
president has I think a decent case to
make that the end of his first year he's
accomplished a lot that people people
feel good about the economy a consumer
confidence is high stock market is high
unemployment unemployment is low
everything is sort of going his way
economically so I think that it's very
hard to disrupt that right now and if
you know the Democrats they're gonna
have to defend all of those seats that
Chris Wallace was talking about they
might be able to pick up a couple of
places I think the thing to really think
about is the candidate recruitment and
in some of these places talking about
the house side for a second you have up
to 17 18 19 people running in some of
these Democratic primaries that's going
to pull a lot of those Democrats way to
the left but we saw in the presidential
election in 2016 that's not where the
country is
I think Alabama is definitely just an
outlier do you think voter patterns are
interesting too maybe compared to
Virginia governor's race but ultimately
Roy Moore this is allegations that he
could not overcome this is specific to
him he's the one who lost the race